well the so-called Defenders of
democracy on the left are praying that
the Supreme Court agrees with their
anti-democratic ideology right now at
least 19 States 19 are still trying to
get Trump knocked off the ballot and
he's fighting back against the onslaught
of legal cases in addition to
challenging those attempts he's trying
to dismiss the case in Georgia against
him claiming presidential immunity
joining us now for more analysis
christoo land Chris Lando former law
clerk for justices Thomas and SC a
former ambassador to Mexico Chris before
we get into that on this issue of Mexico
and the president of Mexico making a
series of Demands of the United States
On the Border you worked in the Trump
Administration how much leverage do we
have over Mexico on the issue of
immigration La we have incredible
leverage over Mexico I mean we are
Mexico's largest trading partner by far
uh when this kind of immigration issue
flared up in early 2019 president Trump
made it very clear that our relations
with Mexico would not proceed normally
if Mexico didn't crack down on the
immigration that the Mexican Government
at that time had encouraged and boy you
saw that change almost overnight if this
Administration and the Republicans and
the Senate wanted this border crisis to
end it could end how quickly overnight
this is a man-made crisis Laura there is
no uh hurricane suddenly that people are
fleeing from this is people moving with
their feet because they think they will
get into the United States and be able
to stay here if it is clear to them that
they're not going to be able to get in
the United States and stay here they're
not going to come 85% allowed allowed
wave them of course that's the problem
85% all right I want to get into some of
these challenges um 19 states trying to
disqualify the president from the side
that says they're all for democracy
Laura you know people think that they
are going to beat Donald Trump through
the courts this is the problem we have
nowadays I mean you you got to win this
election fair and square at The Ballot
Box people are entitled to their views
of President Trump but the thought that
that the courts are going to do the
dirty work for them and disqualify him
uh I think it's a pipe dream and I what
about this presidential immunity
question because there is some debate
about that whether you're immune to
anything you do while you after you've
sworn into the presidency until you
leave the presidency what about that
argument well it's a very serious
argument that President Trump has raised
actually he's raised it in the Jack
Smith prosecution here in Washington and
there's going to be an oral argument
held on that tomorrow in the court of
appeals for the DC circuit so what's the
panel do you know it's two Biden judges
uh and a uh and an a bush one judge uh
so it's a you know it's a pretty heavily
Biden they have the majority thought on
where that will go you think you know I
I would have to say given the fact that
the judges granted Jack Smith's
extraordinary motion to expedite that
that they're going to rule in Jack
Smith's favor that the two judges and
the majority there um but you know
ultimately that's going to have to be
decided by the Supreme Court Laura and
that's the important point I wanted to
make on on Trump's bringing up this
immunity issue in Georgia that has very
serious uh procedural as well as
substantive ramifications for the
Georgia case because these immunity
issues are whether you're entitled to
immunity from going to trial in the
first place so you have to have an
appell at court that normally doesn't
look at a trial court until it's over
but when you have an issue like immunity
that has to go up the court of appeals
before the trial takes place so these
are preliminary issues that require some
appell at guidance appellant guidance
takes time I think this immunity issue
is going to have to go to the Supreme
Court of the United States 81% of
Democrats Chris um believe that Trump
should be essentially you know La that's
what's so sad I mean these issues like
immunity for presidential actions they
transcend the particular person that
issue I mean are are 81% of Democrats
happy with the thought that President
Biden could be criminally charged by
some grand jury in Texas after his term
in office is over that's the Pandora's
Box that's been opened now if we start
to say that presidents have no immunity
for their uh actions within the Outer
Perimeter of their office it's open
season on the president all right Chris
great to see you tonight thank you hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else